sie sind uns aus Los Angeles
zugeschaltet ich habe es eben schon
gesagt wir haben das eben gehört diese
unglaublichen Umstände da geht jemand
auf Geschäftsreise in den USA fliegt
über Deutschland über Dubai nach Indien
und wird einfach mitten auf dem Weg in
Dubai verschleppt und entführt zu Beginn
vielleicht die Frage wann hatten Sie
Kontakt zum letzten Mal zu ihrem Vater
was wissen sie von ihm wo ist er wie
geht es ihm
wir wissen seit zweieinhalb Jahren nicht
wo mein Vater überhaupt ist das kann uns
keiner sagen das heißt diese Entführung
geht immer noch weiter er ist nicht
entführt worden und er ist jetzt
inhaftiert wir wissen immer noch nicht
vor wo er ist das als er ist immer noch
eine Geisel niemand hat Zugang zu meinem
Vater niemand hat ihn seit zweieinhalb
Jahren gesehen außerdem Menschen die ihn
entführt haben ich habe seit eineinhalb
Jahren nicht mehr mit meinem Vater
gesprochen im ersten Jahr durfte ich
einige Male alle paar Monate mit meinem
Vater sprechen das sind komplett
kontrollierte Gespräche das heißt er
sagt uns jedes Mal hier sitzen jetzt
zehn oder 15 Wächter neben mir die
passen auf was ich sage er darf nur das
sagen was sie wollen wenn er irgendwas
versucht uns zu sagen wird das Gespräch
abgebrochen und diese Gespräche waren
auch dafür gedacht damit wir mit dem
Regime mitspielen also Druck auf uns
auch zu üben damit wir falsche Dokumente
schreiben das mit der Briefe schreiben
damit wir ähm Software auf unsere
Computerladen die sie dann später in
ihrem Schauprozessen als Beweismaterial
benutzen können und als wir nicht
mitgespielt haben als wir als wir das
nicht wollten haben sie den Kontakt
komplett abgebrochen für neun Monate und
im letzten Jahr durfte er nur zweimal
mit meiner Mutter sprechen und nur
einmal dieses Jahr mit meiner Mutter
sprechen und was wissen sie können Sie
uns sagen über den Zustand ihres Vaters
sie haben berichtet dass er mindestens
20 Kilo Gewicht verloren hat dass er
kaum noch laufen kann dass ihm seine
Zähne ausgefallen sind dass er auch an
Parkinson erkrankt ist das heißt was
können Sie uns über seine
gesundheitlichen Zustand sagen
die Information die wir haben sind das
meiste ist noch vom ersten Jahr indem
man noch mehr mit uns sprechen konnte er
man muss ein bisschen zwischen den
Zeilen lesen also er sagt uns dann so
was wie zum Beispiel ich habe heute Brei
gegessen weil ich keine Zähne mehr habe
und sobald wir nachfragen warum hast du
keine Zähne mehr kann er darauf nicht
antworten dann müssen wir auch das
nächste Gespräch warten und dann
vielleicht noch mal nachfragen was ist
mit deinen Zähnen passiert dann sagt er
die sind gebrochen da muss man sich
wieder vorstellen warum sind deine Zähne
gebrochen also dass er darauf andeuten
will dass er gefoltert wird in jedem
Gespräch sagt er uns dass er komplett
alleine ist also er ist jetzt genau 950
Tage in kompletter isolations- und
Einzelhaft das heißt er hat keinen
Menschen mit dem er sprechen kann
außerdem die immer was böses wollen er
hat keinen Zugang zur zum zur frischen
Luft Licht er kann nicht unterscheiden
ob es Tag oder Nacht ist er er er er hat
er bekommt seine Medikamente die er
früher alle drei Stunden brauchte für
parkinsons
Menschen ist das sehr wichtig dass Sie
das auf die Minute bekommen weil sie
dann nicht gehen können weil sie nicht
atmen können weil sie Schmerzen bekommen
die bekommt er spät die werden ihn spät
gegeben oder nicht die richtige Dosis er
hat Herzschmerzen im Ruhestand und ich
weiß als Krankenschwester das ist ein
Anzeichen dafür dass mein Herzstillstand
bekommen kann ihm geht es schrecklich
also alleine im Gefängnis dort wo sie
ihn halten in diesen Folter kann man ist
es schon kaum auszuhalten und jetzt
wollen sie ihn auch noch hinrichten
öffentlich hinrichten sie haben das eben
kurz angedeutet wichtig dass du
verstehen sie sind gelernte intensiv
Krankenschwester das heißt sie wissen
genau was das alles bedeutet medizinisch
dieses Urteil ein offenkundig
politisches Urteil diese vielen
schaub-prozesse 7 oder 8 mittlerweile
wann haben Sie von diesem Urteil
erfahren und wie groß ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieses Urteil
tatsächlich auch in aller nächster Zeit
vollstreckt wird gibt den Fall eines
Schweden der ebenfalls festgehalten wird
von diesem Regime die glaube ich schon
vor sechs Jahren zum Tode verurteilt
worden ist und immer wieder wird diese
Frist verlängert
ganz genau also ehrlich gesagt das
Urteil von meinem für meinen Vater das
Todesurteil wurde vor 16 Jahren schon
gesprochen als mein Vater in Amerika
eine Webseite kreiert hat in der die
Menschen aus dem Iran direkt unzensiert
berichten konnten da wurde er schon zum
zur Zielscheibe des Regimes da wollten
sie ihn schon umbringen die haben in
2009 ein Agenten nach Los Angeles
geschickt der ihn umbringen sollte das
wurde Gott sei Dank vereitelt aber
dieses Urteil das er sterben soll bei
denen weil er den Menschen eine Stimme
gegeben hat eine Plattform das gibt es
schon seit 16 Jahren sobald Sie ihn ähm
entführt haben wurde uns gesagt es wird
ein Schauprozess gemacht er wird das
Todesurteil bekommen die haben sich auf
das Schauprozess vorbereitet und es
wurde von vorne rein vom Regime vom
regime-anwalt von allen gesagt dieses
Urteil steht schon also es ist das ist
ein Theater das ist ein schaubutter das
ist alles kontrolliert das sind keine
echten Richter und genauso ist es jetzt
im Obersten Gerichtshof da sitzt keiner
und guckt sich die Unterlagen an und
sieht da gibt es keine BE besonders
freigesprochen werden sondern die sitzen
dort und warten bis sie von oben dein
Befehl bekommen jetzt wird das Urteil
bestätigt und die Sache ist tot ernst
weil seit er das Urteil seit das Urteil
gesprochen worden ist zeigen sie im
iranischen Staatsfernsehen nach den
Nachrichten Propaganda Videos rund um
die Uhr um mein Vater als kriminellen
darzustellen um die Bevölkerung mit
Gehirnwäsche darauf vorzubereiten dass
es vielleicht bald ein eine Hinrichtung
gibt und ich habe gehört dass in
karatsch in einer Stadt die schon
angefangen haben die Menschen aus den
Zellen rauszuholen und mit Massen in
Richtung anfangen wollen also es ist
jetzt wirklich fünf vor zwölf wir haben
wirklich keine Zeit zu verlieren und wir
wissen noch nicht mal ob mein Vater noch
lebt da wir keinen Zugang zu haben also
es könnte sein in einigen Fällen sie
haben jetzt gerade den äh Schweden
angesprochen er hat übrigens der Schwede
Ahmadi hat das Todesurteil bekommen für
eine von den Anschuldigung die sich
jetzt in Kontakte von meinem Vater
wiedergefunden hat also dass die nehmen
immer dieselben anschauen copy-pace in
verschiedene Akte rein und geben damit
diese diese
Todesurteile in dem Fall waren es sechs
Jahre in der die Familie jeden jedes Mal
zählt wird jetzt holen wir ihn raus
jetzt richten wir ihn hin es gibt aber
auch Fälle wo das wo es noch nicht mal
dazu gekommen ist dass es in Berufung
gegangen ist die Person schon
hingerichtet worden ist der Familie
nichts gesagt wurde und dann Wochen
später gesagt wurden ach der ist jetzt
schon längst tot das kann auch sein
deswegen wissen wir nicht wie viel Zeit
wir haben was wir jedenfalls alle spüren
ist ihre tiefe Verzweiflung ich kann das
sehr gut nachvollziehen das ist
grauenvoll Sebastian vieler ist bei uns
im ihm gesagt lange für die Polizei
gearbeitet mittlerweile für die Kollegen
der SPD im Bundestag jemand mit dem wir
sehr gut auch darüber sprechen können
welche Sanktionen dieses Regime
möglicherweise treffen würden aber
zunächst mal die Frage was ist das für
eine Lage auch für ein Land jetzt wie
Deutschland da sitzt einer deiner
Staatsbürger sitzt dort im Gefängnis
es ist Willkür es sind willkürliche
Urteile sind politische Urteile an
politischer Schauprozess der dort
stattfindet und die Frage bis zu welchem
Punkt bist du bereit dich erpressen zu
lassen was unternimmt die
Bundesregierung seit ich weiß dass ich
hier eingeladen wurde habe ich über die
Antwort nachgedacht und es gibt nicht
die einfache Antwort
ich komme gerade aus Brüssel und wir
haben natürlich ähnliche Diskussion
wollte ich gerade sagen genau und ich
habe auch mit Belgien gesprochen
beziehungsweise natürlich mit eu-leuten
die die diese Diskussion da live und
sehr intensiv verfolgt haben dort gibt
es die Diskussion dass man sozusagen
eine Art Gefangenen Austausch versucht
zu organisieren in Belgien sogar ein
Gesetz deswegen geändert wird und auch
in Belgien wird das aus
vieler Gründen natürlich ein Stück weit
kontrovers diskutiert weil natürlich auf
der einen Seite die erpressbank
potenzielle Erpressbarkeit der statisch
steht und auf der anderen Seite die
richtige schlussform dass wir natürlich
versuchen jedes Menschenleben zu retten
so und aus für dieses Dilemma werden wir
weder heute Abend auch in der Zukunft
eine einfache Überschrift finden man
muss glaube ich noch dazu erzählen weil
das jetzt heute an und ich gesagt worden
ist all das bettet sich ja ein in eine
pseudo-theologische Ideologie die sich
dadurch auszeichnet dass sie zu tiefst
menschenverachtend ist homophob ich
glaube 4000 Homosexuelle sind an Kränen
aufgehangen worden sie ist zutiefst
Israel feindlich und antisemitisch der
israelische Staat soll bis aus dem Tod
bekämpft werden
das heißt dahinter steht die Ideologie
Millionen von Jüdinnen und Juden zu
ermorden also das heißt wir sprechen
sozusagen über ein horror-regime wie wir
uns das kaum hier in unsere Welt
ausmalen können das muss man glaube ich
zuerst mal voran schicken wenn wir uns
darüber unterhalten mit welchen
Möglichkeiten haben wir denn überhaupt
verhandlungs- oder druckpotenzial um im
Einzelfall Erfolg zu haben und das macht
so ein bisschen deutlich wie schwer die
Antwort erst also zwei Dinge werden
deutlich die es gibt keine einfache
Antworten der zweite Teil ist
viele Dinge die eine Antwort sein
könnten sollten wir heute Abend nicht
besprechen weil natürlich auch das
wissen wir aus anderen
Verhandlungssituationen viel versucht
wird im Hintergrund sowohl im Druck als
auch an Verhandlungsmöglichkeiten zu
erarbeiten also beides gehörten bis zum
ganzen Bild bevor wir gleich zu
Friedrich Merz gehen können Sie noch
einmal ganz kurz Herr Fiedler in wenigen
Sätzen skizzieren was dieser belgische
Fall ist was ist dort die Geschichte der
Bergische Fall den habe ich schon kurz
skizziert also in aller Kürze geht es
eben um eine ähnliche Konstellation wie
sie jetzt hier gerade ist aber es geht
auf der anderen Seite gibt es jemanden
der den äh das iranische Regime gerne
aus belgischen Gefängnissen
herausbekommen möchte
das weiß ich gar nicht mehr auswendig
das wissen Sie vielleicht er wurde in
Bayern festgesetzt er war in Österreich
in der Botschaft und wollte einen also
hat dabei unterstützt einen äh Terror
einen Bombenanschlag auf oppositionell
in Paris auszuführen der ist dann
gestoppt worden aber erst dann in Bayern
also festgesetzt worden
Verbrecher sozusagen auf der einen Seite
und es geht um den Gefangenenaustausch
verstehe und das wird deswegen in
Belgien natürlich kontrovers diskutiert
weil die Belgien und Belgier sagen wir
verstehen absolut und wir wollen
natürlich auch unseren Menschen hier
befreien auf der anderen Seite fragen
Sie sich was passiert am nächsten Tag
sozusagen gelernt dass Regime dadurch
wie westliche Demokratien dadurch
erpressbar werden und ich will deswegen
auch gar nicht eine Antwort geben
sondern will nur sagen also weil er
keine keine einfache Lösung aufzeigen
will nur sagen
dazu muss gehören dass im Hintergrund
auf der Ebene von Nachrichtendienst und
Dingen die wir nicht besprechen können
ebenfalls Anstrengung unternommen werden
Friedrich Merz hat sich heute
dankenswerterweise für uns Zeit genommen
vielen Dank Herr März der diesen Fall
ich habe es von so ausgedrückt ein
bisschen zu seiner Sache gemacht erstens
die Frage
warum und die zweite Frage was können
wir tun was sollten wir unternehmen
Sebastian viele hat dass die Ländern den
wir stecken gerade ziemlich gut
beschrieben wie ich finde
ich bin von bundestagskollegen vor
einigen Monaten auf diesen Fall
aufmerksam gemacht worden und gebeten
worden wie andere auch schon vorher für
diesen konkreten Fall die politische
Patenschaft zu übernehmen ich habe das
aus Überzeugung getan vor allem weil es
hier um einen so ungeheuerlichen Vorgang
geht nämlich die vorangegangene
Entführung eines deutschen Staatsbürgers
dann dort auch die Verurteilung und
jetzt auch das Todesurteil vor zwei
Wochen ich habe mich mit der Familie
vor 14 Tagen in den USA getroffen und
habe mir dort auch noch einmal den Fall
erläutern lassen und ich bin noch
entsetzter als ich vorher war weil ich
auch die näheren Umstände dieser
Entführung und auch dieses
Schauprozesses noch einmal sehr
authentisch und auch ja sehr will ich
soll ich sagen wirklich jedes Mitgefühl
auslösend
geschildert bekommen habe ich denke wir
können hier politischen Druck ausüben
ich will ganz ausdrücklich sagen allein
die Tatsache dass das heute abend in
ihrer Sendung zum Thema gemacht wird
wird nicht ohne Wirkung bleiben wir
wissen dass die iranische Staatsführung
auch auf so etwas schaut das
öffentlicher Druck auch in einem oder
anderen Fall schon geholfen hat und hier
handelt es sich insofern um einen ganz
besonderen Fall weil es eben ein
deutscher Staatsbürger ist und ich finde
dass wir hier jenseits aller
politischen Diskussionen die wir zur
führen haben auch zwischen Regierung und
Oppositionen doch uns gemeinsam dafür
einsetzen sollten das so etwas nicht
geschieht dass hier wenigstens faire
Verfahren gesichert werden das
konsularische Betreuung ermöglicht wird
all das ermöglicht das Müller Regime
nicht ich habe mittlerweile zweimal den
iranischen Botschafter in Berlin
angeschrieben ich habe ihn gesprochen
und ich habe ihm auch sehr deutlich
gesagt dass dieses Urteil Folgen haben
muss und haben wird und wenn es zu einer
Vollstreckung kommen sollte kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen dass die
diplomatischen Beziehungen zwischen
Deutschland und dem Iran einfach
fortgesetzt werden mit welchen
Konsequenzen also wenn man das jetzt so
sagen ne und das zeigt ist deswegen bin
ich sehr froh darüber dass wir versuchen
heute hier eine differenzierte
Diskussion zu führen das ist ja der
erste Reflex den jeder hat zusammen pass
auf das wird Konsequenzen für euch haben
dann weisen wir beispielsweise den
Botschafter des Landes aus die Frage ist
Herr März wie groß ist dann die Gefahr
dass wir gar kein gesprächskanal mehr
dann zum Beispiel nach Teheran haben das
heißt dass die Dinge am Ende im Ergebnis
noch schlimmer werden
das ist in der Tat eine Abwägung die wir
vornehmen müssen Herr Lanz auf der
anderen Seite muss dieses Regime wissen
dass es immer weiter auch in die
internationale Isolierung Gerät ich
hoffe und denke dass die Europäische
Union hier auch gemeinsam vorgehen muss
dass das nicht allein Deutschland tun
sollte wir haben ja eben auch von dem
weiteren Fall eines Schweden gehört also
hier geht es auch um europäische Politik
aber wir müssen ganz einfach klar machen
das ist er mit einem solchen Land das
von einem solchen Regime geführt wird
auch keine normalen Beziehungen und
keine normalen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
mehr geben kann es muss dann noch härter
sanktioniert werden wir müssen hier auch
unsere Werte verteidigen und gerade an
einem solchen Fall wird deutlich was
auch freie Presse was öffentliche Maja
freie Meinungsäußerung für Werte sind
und die sollten wir hier schon auch
gemeinsam verteilen darf ich nochmal
einmal den Punkt machen bevor wir gleich
zu Gilde sein kommt die Frage sozusagen
dieser Erpressbarkeit die Idee des
Gefangenen austauscht du du greifst dir
einfach Leute irgendwo auf der Welt und
wir werden gleich hören wie es ihm im
Fall ihres Vaters gewesen ist grauenvoll
also wenn du das erlebst wenn du das
verstehst wie das abgelaufen ist dann
kapierst du dass du nirgendwo auf der
Welt offensichtlich vor diesem Regime
wirklich sicher bist
die versuchen sozusagen andere Staaten
zur Pressung zu sagen pass auf ihr gebt
uns unseren Mann und dann kriegt ihr
euren Mann zurück wie stehen Sie dazu
Herr Merz kann man also einen solchen
Deal der es dann an dem Punkt ist kann
man den machen kann man sich als Starter
pressbar machen
der Lanz das ist natürlich die völlig
richtig gestellte Frage aber man muss ja
auch die andere Frage stellen was wäre
denn wenn wir uns gegen solche Willkür
nicht mehr zur Wehr setzen und insofern
denke ich dass wir hier gar keinen
anderen Weg haben als diesen Fall
öffentlich zu machen dem Regime klar und
deutlich zu sagen dass wir nicht bereit
sind das zu akzeptieren und sie haben es
eben in der Sendung schon zu Beginn
angesprochen auch die Frage wie wir mit
denen hier in Deutschland lebenden und
tätigen Vertretern dieses Regimes
umgehen ähm blicken wir nach Hamburg in
diese sogenannte Blaue Moschee ein
islamisches iranisches Kulturzentrum ein
sogenanntes Kulturzentrum ich denke es
ist an der Zeit dass über eine
Schließung dieses Kulturzentrums
ernsthaft nachgedacht und auch
entschieden wird also wir sollten hier
wirklich in aller Konsequenz unsere
Werte unsere Freiheit auch verteidigen
und wir wissen ja dass mittlerweile eine
große Zahl von iranischen Agenten in
Deutschland tätig ist die hier auch
dieses Terrorregime unterstützen und in
Deutschland dafür sorgen dass zum
Beispiel so etwas geschieht wie diese
Entführungen und andere Dinge also der
Rechtsstaat Bundesrepublik Deutschland
muss nicht nur nach innen gegenüber
seinen eigenen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
auch gegenüber denen die hier tätig sind
einfach Zähne zeigen ich glaube es gibt
keine wirklich bessere Alternative dafür
so Gilde sahelis bei uns über die Blaue
Moschee man vielleicht gleich noch zwei
drei Sätze verlieren seit Jahren
umstritten was mit dieser Moschee
passieren soll seit Jahren bestätigen
wir uns gegenseitig wir wollen dieses
sogenannte islamische Zentrum schließen
passiert aber aus einem Grund der mir
nicht klar ist immer noch nicht sie
sagen Frau sahibi dieses Regime benutzt
Menschen als Faust fand und Friedrich
Merz hat eben schon kurz angedeutet der
Arm ist lang sehr sehr lang so lang dass
auch Menschen wie sie zum Beispiel wenn
sie in Deutschland auf die Straße gehen
und gegen das Regime dort demonstrieren
sich überlegen müssen was sie tun wo sie
gesehen werden weil es unter Patienten
für ihre Familie im Iran die Sie mit
Sicherheit auch haben Verwandte
Konsequenzen haben könnte also wie groß
ist diese Bedrohung auch auf deutschem
Staatsgebiet dies überall auf der Welt
groß ich glaube
dass
vor allem in Deutschland aber auch in
der Europäischen Union in Europa
insgesamt eine sehr große Naivität
gegenüber diesem iranischen Regime seit
Jahren schon herrscht und auch eine sehr
für mich ein unverständliche Nähe zu
diesem Regime immer da war und das das
Regime wirklich eigentlich den
Regierungen auf der Nase herumtanzt also
vor 2015 hat sich das Regime eigentlich
vor allem auf amerikanische
StaatsbürgerInnen versteift und seit
2015 sind es fast nur noch europäische
die inhaftiert werden
und ich finde den also man muss sich
klar sein das ist ein das ist
tatsächlich an Terrorregime und man
sieht es ganz gut daran
vor ein paar Wochen es gibt ein großes
exil-medium das heißt wir waren
international das sitzt eigentlich in
London und die Terrorgefahr die war so
groß von der Metropolitan Police
bestätigt dass dieses gesamte Medium die
Schotten dicht machen musste und nach
Washington umziehen es gab keinerlei
aufregt Aufregung Aufmerksamkeit wenn
ich mir überlegt das wäre der is gewesen
oder al-Qaida wir hätten wahrscheinlich
eine Sondersendung nach der anderen
gehabt aber der ist der ist da und der
wird was ich gerne verstehen würde es
wird ignoriert und das verstehe ich
nicht und ich glaube das hat auch mit
einer
ganz großen Naivität mit diesem zu tun
dann lass uns doch weil Friedrich Merz
auch glaube ich in Kürze wieder weg muss
an dem Punkt das einmal kurz diskutieren
vielleicht an Gazelle auch in Los
Angeles die Frage
wie geht ihrer Erklärung dafür dass wir
da so naiv sind dass wir diesen langen
Armen dieses Regimes und wenn das auch
gleich von Ihnen hören wie diese
Entführung abgelaufen ist dass wir das
so ignorieren und im Grunde nicht
wirklich verstehen mit wem was dazu tun
haben
ich weiß nicht ob wir das nicht
verstehen oder ob wir einfach wegschauen
wollen weil es einfach einfach ist weil
es da andere Motive gibt weil es da
vielleicht business deals gibt weil die
Dollar Seins halt irgendwie mehr wert
sind als Menschenleben und wenn man
denkt man kann das einfach ignorieren
und nicht darauf eingehen da das
islamische Regime hat mit Geiselnahmen
angefangen vor 44 Jahren wurden die
ersten Geiseln genommen das waren
Amerikaner das war damals überall im
Staatsfernsehen der Bundespräsident hat
das laut gesagt alle haben mitgefiebert
jeder Tag wurde gesagt heute sind die
geil sind seit 16 Tagen dort alle haben
sich dafür interessiert
amerikanischen Botschaften ja genau
genau wissen Sie noch wie das damals wie
groß das in den Medien oder wie wichtig
das war und jetzt ist mein Vater dort
fast 1000 Tagen als Geisel und er wird
jetzt wird erst darüber gesprochen das
heißt wir haben das einfach ausgeblendet
es hat sich ja nichts verändert diese
Geiselnahme haben sich ja
weiterentwickelt sind ja immer wieder
passiert immer wieder dasselbe immer
wieder angenommen wir kaufen die raus
das ist ja auch kein Problem wenn man
das erste Mal eine Geiselnahme sieht
auch eine normale geisela wenn jemand in
der Bank Geiseln nimmt dann versucht man
natürlich als erstes alles zu machen um
die daraus zu holen das ist ja auch okay
das aber danach setzt man sich doch
nicht mit den Geiseln nehmen an den
Tisch macht mit den Verträge lädt Sie zu
unseren Konferenzen ein Human Rights
Council und so weiter lässt sie dort
reden macht mit den Geschäfte man
nachdem man die Geiseln rausgeholt hat
dann muss doch Druck gemacht werden dann
müssen doch Menschen zu Rechenschaft
gezogen werden und das passiert nicht
wir wollen unsere Geiseln raus wir
machen unser pressbar und dann setzen
uns wieder mit den anderen Tisch dann
machen wir mit den Deals dann laden wir
Sie ein dann lassen wir den den
Außenminister des terror-regimes in
unserer Konferenz in Genf über
Menschenrechte sprechen und laden den
ein und und kein interessiert also das
ist einfach so verrückt wie wir mit
Terroristen umgehen und die einfach
nicht als Terroristen sehen oder nicht
sehen wollen weil die Bilder die jetzt
seit fünf Monaten sehen auf den
Straßenfest im Iran die gibt es seit 44
Jahren Menschen wie mein Vater zeigen
diese Bilder seit 44 Jahren und es wurde
einfach aktiv weggeschaut und das ist
das Problem Gott sei Dank schauen jetzt
alle hin Gott sei Dank können wir uns
jetzt nicht mehr verstecken und sagen
wir haben davon nichts gewusst weil alle
jetzt hingucken weil alle diese
Schauprozesse sehen bei alle diese
Hinrichtungen sehen weil alle den
Terrorismus sehen weil alle diese
Entführungen nicht sehen und die geilen
Namen jetzt sehen es wird immer noch
nicht angesprochen wenn über meinen
Vater gesprochen wird wird immer noch
von einem
besseren Prozess oder oder irgendwelchen
solchen Sachen gesehen es geht darum
dass ein Mensch entführt worden ist
entführt worden
gehängt werden soll genau
die große Frage also ich habe schon das
Gefühl dass gerade Deutschland da eine
große Verantwortung zukommt
Deutschland ist glaube ich der
wichtigste Handelspartner für dieses
mulariechen deswegen noch mal die Frage
also wollen wir es nicht sehen
sondern wirst nicht sehen haben wir so
große Wirtschaftsinteressen dass wir uns
an einer bestimmten Punkt nicht zu sehr
aus dem Fenster lehnen können oder
wollen wir uns sicher pressbar machen
werden sie bereit wenn sie
verantwortlich wären wenn sie Kanzler
dieses Landes wären werden Sie bereit so
sagen wir stellen die
Geschäftsbeziehungen ein was dann
konkret bedeutet deutsche Unternehmen
verdienen weniger Geld was im Zweifel
bedeutet deutsche Arbeitsplätze gehen
verloren was im Zweifel bedeutet
deutscher Wohlstand geht verloren sind
wir dazu wirklich bereit jenseits von
Sonntagsreden das was wir dann
einfordern unsere Werte hochhalten sind
wir dazu wirklich ernsthaft bereit Frage
Herr lanzt die Antwort auf Ihre Frage
ist ein uneingeschränktes Ja wenn wir
nicht mehr bereit sind unsere Freiheit
wirklich zu verteidigen und wenn uns
Geschäft wichtiger ist als Freiheit dann
haben wir unseren moralischen Kompass
verloren und das hat dann auch nichts
mehr mit sozialer Marktwirtschaft zu tun
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist nicht
ungebundenes Geld verdient sondern
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist Wirtschaft
nach Regeln und diese Regeln gelten
gelten im Inneren und diese Regeln die
müssen selbstverständlich auch in den
außenwirtschaftlichen Verhältnissen
gelten das heißt nicht dass alle Lupen
reine Demokratien sein müssen mit denen
wir Handel treiben auf dieser Welt aber
mit terrorgeschrieben wir wissen doch
vom Iran dass er den internationalen
Terrorismus maßgeblich finanziert das
gilt das dort verdient wird ist blutiges
Geld die Antwort auf Ihre Frage ist
eindeutig und klar und ohne jede
Einschränkung ja